hello everyone and welcome to a very
interesting suggestion I received
yesterday via email H it is from a title
Tuesday that was played on February the
7th and it is Ilia 2700 versus Magnus
Carlson now uh Elia is not really 2700
in the uh chess.com platform he's
actually
20233 rated and as you can see Magnus is
uh some 1,00 rating points higher rated
than him and he chooses a very very
interesting opening for this game and uh
the reason he's facing such a much lower
rated opponent is because he lost the
first game he loses the first game and
then he gets paired against a lower
rated opponent and he decides to have
some fun so let's see what happened here
Elia decided to open with D4 and Magnus
went for Knight to A6 this is the
so-called Australian Australian defense
and uh there are well only a handful of
games in the database but already after
C4 Magnus goes for Knight the H6 as well
and it is now as of move two that we
have a completely new game so Magnus
goes really out of his weight throw his
opponent out of any possible Theory
knowledge and um I don't know how how
would you rate to this position uh what
is White's plan even how do you approach
this obviously the knights are are
poorly placed but you know that Magnus
will probably play some thing in the
future put them to maybe C7 F7 control
the center so you also have to be ready
for that do do you capture the Knight I
mean it would be silly to give up a
strong Bishop for a knight like that so
best is just to continue developing and
putting your pieces on optimal squares
which is exactly what Elia does he plays
Knight to C3 and as I don't know who
this is I'm wearing a hoodie to honor
the hoodie guy as I usually do and here
Magnus strikes with Pawn to E5 bit weird
as the E5 square is undefended but we've
seen this um in many other openings such
as the The Budapest Gambit and many
others so D captures on E5 and now D6 uh
he he is cementing his Pawn sacrifice
and he wants to develop his pieces with
Tempo so Knight to F3 three and now
Bishop to E6 here Magnus even said that
he's hoping that his opponent isn't
really 2700 uh because he might run into
some trouble he didn't say he was going
to lose or anything that is you know it
might be awkward a little bit uh so
Bishop to G5 going after magnus's Queen
and he just plays Queen to D7 later on
once the tension in the center is
resolved he will probably kick away the
bishop maybe Castle Queen side and so on
so here Pawn to E3 the bishop has been
developed now it's time to develop the
light Square bishop and now Knight to G4
already putting pressure on that Center
D5 Pawn is attacked so e captures on D6
we have Bishop captures on D6 and now H3
kicking away magnus's Knight we have
Knight to F6 and here Elia decides to
capture Bishop captures and G captures
and here you have this position where
okay Magnus is down upon but he has a
very active position his Bishop pair is
uh in the game controlling some very
nice squares he does have the bishop
pair his opponent does not and he's
ready to Castle Queen side he does have
the semi-open G file to use for for
attacks and um you know things are
looking well but if white plays
something like Queen to D4 a beautiful
centralizing move already putting
pressure on F6 Magnus could run into
some trouble but his opponent does not
and here Magnus even said that uh if his
opponent plays something like A3 B4 that
he could be in a lot of trouble but he
played Knight to D5 and Magnus said that
this is pretty a pretty horrible move as
it does absolutely nothing so here
Magnus castled Queen side and um what is
the Knight really doing on D5 you can
never capture on F6 if you capture on F6
then just Bishop to B4 check and you
resign uh the D2 square is W that's a
weird Arrow the D2 square is covered
three times so you cannot block with the
Knight and if you play King E2 then just
Bishop captures on C4 and it's Checkmate
okay once you give up the queen it's
Checkmate so uh you have to do something
else Bishop to E2 of course Elia agrees
that the king especially with magnus's
development has no um no place being in
the center of the board and Magnus just
kicks away the Knight with C6 and again
you cannot capture on F6 the same idea
still applies with Bishop to B4 so
Knight back to C3 and now Rook H to G8
and now Magnus said that he will play
every move with um uh with a threat so
the threat here is that if white C if
white could Castle then white could be
even maybe fine but if if he castles
then Magnus just sacrifices everything
and checkmates the white king Rook
captures on G2 check King captures
Bishop captures on H3 check and now of
course you're going to move away from
the G file but Magnus would sacrifice
the bishop as well because then comes
Queen G4 check and once the king moves
Queen H3 check and once the king moves
now Rook G8 is deadly you have to block
with the Knight and then Queen to H2 of
course will be Checkmate so after Rook H
to G8 there is only one good move for
white and Ilia plays it he plays King to
F1 and now Magnus wasn't really sure on
how to continue the game he played Queen
to E7 now he is threatening some
discoveries as the rook and the queen
are on the same file but his opponent of
course moves the queen queen to A4 and
now some unpleasant uh surprises may
occur on the A6 Square so Magnus first
moves the king king to B8 and now Pawn
to A3 preparing Pawn to B4 and again
Magnus says um okay a lot of suboptimal
moves have been played by Elia but still
there's no clear way on how to take
advantage of of the position and if you
really allow the engine to Crunch the
numbers uh the engine will say it's an
equal position so okay we have Bishop to
E5 now Magnus threatening to capture on
C3 this will prevent white from playing
B4 uh that already could be considered a
victory in itself and of course IIA does
not allow that Knight captures on E5 F
captures on E5 and now Pawn to B4 going
after Pawn to B5 and Magnus has to
figure out how to get out of this so he
plays Queen to G5 now threatens Queen
captur and G2 uh and Bishop to F3
blocking Rook to G1 is the more precise
move but it looks weird to play because
how are you ever getting that Rook um
inter the game and also how are you ever
putting your king to to a safe place to
maybe activate the Rook anytime soon so
Bishop to F3 was played maybe preparing
King E2 with some B Rook to D1 action H
but now Magnus goes for Pawn to F5 and
Ilia hung a pawn here with Bishop
captures on C4 when he played Bishop to
F3 but Magnus ignores it he just played
Pawn to F5 but later he admitted that uh
he he never actually saw this only on
the second move after Ilia played G3
Magnus played Bishop captures on C4 with
check and now the only move that sort of
keeps Ilia in the game is Bishop to E2
but he played Queen to G2 and now it is
all over Magnus plays Rook to D2 and now
with the terrible threat of Queen
captures on G3 as the F2 Pawn is spinned
and they couldn't really decide what to
call this check what kind of a check is
this it's not really a discovered check
so if you have any any cool names on how
we could refer to this check in the
future feel free to comment on that in
the comment section so here Ilia played
King to G1 he unpinned from the f file
uh but now the position is completely
winning for Magnus and you can even uh
pause the video and try to find the
winning idea Magnus was so happy when he
saw this King to G1 move that he got up
from his chair as he was streaming this
event and he said that the you know
things everything in the world happens
for a reason because he lost in the
first round he got to play against this
2,000 rated opponent guy who uh
performed admirably but now it's time he
gets the hammer as he put it so he
didn't okay uh have you paused the video
have you found the correct solution um I
will give you a couple of seconds extra
if you guys want to decide on that uh so
for those of you uh who were able to do
it congratulations and not going for a d
move as Magnus referred to it and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Queen captures on G3 with
check it's of course the move that
Magnus saw instantly but he first played
Knight to C5 which he said that it it
serves really no purpose he just wants
to sacrifice an extra piece before
executing the queen sacrifice and he
called it a d move and then okay the
queen is attacked you have to do
something there is no good Square for
the queen so you have to capture B
captures on C5 was played and now Magnus
played Queen captures on G3 I do it in
slow motion but the queen is so close to
the pawn I can't really do it so Queen
captures on G3 F captures on G3 and now
Rook captures on G3 with check now the
King has no squares as the bishop covers
the F1 Square so Bishop to G2 was played
and now again Magnus couldn't really
decide which Rook to use to deliver
Checkmate uh so he decided to play a
principled move and it's a principled
idea to always put your Rooks on the
seventh rank so he played Rook G Capt on
G2 uh and it is now of course um
Checkmate he said it's important to
teach a good habit and putting your
Rooks on the seventh rank is definitely
a good good habit to have uh so really
incredible uh game by Magnus uh um
you've seen how okay you you play this
position and you might think okay if you
saw this you think it's a free elo or
free point or however you want to call
it uh but then he made one one
ill-considered move here after the the F
Pawn was doubled instead of going for
the uh active and centralizing queen to
D4 which controls the entire board and
the queen is very nicely defended on D4
he went for Knight to D5 which looks
great but it does absolutely nothing and
here all of elia's Advantage basically
disappeared after Magnus Castle now he
he was just on equal terms with Magnus
and that's I mean that's okay that's
game over uh so yeah very nicely done by
both of them Elia held his own for a
while but you know yeah it is Magnus
Carlson is playing and he's over like
1,00 points higher rated than him uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it thank you for recommending
such a nice one if you want to see the
actual footage of Magnus streaming this
game and a couple of guys dancing behind
him uh will be in the description below
uh so there we have it I would like to
thank Kik madii Raymond young ging chess
festival.org Dogg Ellen Sol hardstein
and Paul Miller for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and if you don't want
something like this to happen to you do
brush up on your chest first link in the
description below is a link to our
improve app so you can improve um your
chess whenever you're ready uh so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day